lorsque mon grand-père a conçu madiana
lorsque max elysée a conçu madiana il a
été faire une formation chez disney donc
ma diana était vraiment conçu comme un
parc d'attractions initialement il n'y
avait même pas de barrière en fait c'est
à dire que quand vous rentriez sur le
site un peu le concept de de disney sait
que vous arrivez sur un site avec un
environnement différent mais ya pas de
cloison entre les espaces et donc il m'a
diane a été conçu comme ça et l idée de
ceux de ce nouveau projet c'est d'aller
encore plus loin et de redonner encore
un souffle nouveau à son côté un peu
attraction du site
ce que ça change pour monsieur tout le
monde en tout cas ce qu'on espère c'est
que tout martiniquais qui viendra à
madiana sera émerveillé par le site aura
envie de rester posés sur l'esplanade
parce qu'on a mis des bancs pour que les
gens aient envie de s'installer passer
du temps sur le site
ensuite on a essayé de rendre chacun des
espaces attrayant que ce soit l'espace
confiserie que ce soit l'espace jeu
beaucoup plus ludique très coloré un peu
charlie et la chocolaterie sur sur la
partie confiseries et puis le restaurant
elysées qui a été complètement refait et
l'intégralité des salles sur lesquels on
a refait la moquette on a refait les
fauteuils on a refait les tentures et
puis tout le hall on al'avantage d'avoir
un bâtiment qui est encore dans l'air du
temps alors qu'il a quand même vingt ans
en revanche c'est sur les goûts changent
les peintures s'effrite on a envie
d'avoir quelque chose de nouveau
donc au bout de 20 ans était nécessaire
de faire de faire ce lifting et c'est
vrai qu'on l'a agrémenté du changement
du logo de changement de couleur donc ça
fait un vrai changement
mais en réalité le bâtiment est le même
l'investissement a été fait en se disant
qu'on n'augmentera pas le prix du billet
est d'ailleurs il n'ya aucune
augmentation prévue sur en lien avec
les travaux qui ont été réalisés la
seule augmentation qui a eu en juillet
dernier c'est lié à la taxe la fameuse
thèse qui a été nouvellement appliquée
sur les cinémas et sur lesquels on a
augmenté pour essayer de compenser le
prix de la taxe pour le monde n'y avait
pas encore mais voilà donc les seules
augmentations se seraient liées à cette
taxe et en aucun cas aux travaux ce qui
a évolué c'est que avant la sortie audio
visuelle n'était que le cinéma et au fur
et à mesure des années
cette signer cette sortie audio visuel
en fête a été en concurrence avec la
télé puis la vod
puis le streaming netflix et donc du
coup on a complètement changé donc oui
on est le seul cinéma aujourd'hui mais
on est le seul qui reste est aujourd'hui
nos concurrents c'est vrai que c'est par
notre cinéma mais c'est tout ce que vous
avez chez vous sur vos tablettes sur vos
téléphones et qui vous donne moins envie
de rester au cinéma et après sur la
fréquentation on est à peu près sur une
fréquentation assez linéaire ça n'a pas
évolué ça n'a pas diminué donc parfois
vous êtes des petites variations d'une
année à l'autre mais on est aux
alentours entre 900 et 950 mille clients
par an